thanks so much John appreciate it I'm  just having a little frittata here in  the kitchen I'm sure the morning team  would love to join in maybe your fixing  breakfast at home it's a beautiful  morning have a cup of coffee on the  patio but you might need some long  sleeves it's a little cool outside  beautifully clear as we look down across  the southwest so very pretty out there  60 degrees but a lot of neighborhoods  have dropped into the 50s 41 is the dew  point there's still a little moisture  out there but it won't take long to get  rid of it as we'll start to dry out and  warm 86 for the afternoon high we're  gonna look for some 90s to show up by  the weekend breezy winds on Friday those  low 90s Saturday turn into mid 90s  Sunday and even upper 90s next week my  goodness we could be near record highs  as early as Tuesday  let's get